down the ages past Allah sent his
Messengers to deliver humankind from
Darkness to
[Music]
light that's also the ongoing mission of
Islamic Research Foundation or irf
spreading the truth of Allah's final
message to
mankind founded in
1991 irf today offers some of the best
services and facilities in the world for
presenting an understanding of Islam in
an objective and scientific
way its programs are primarily focused
on correcting misconceptions and
promoting understanding of Islam irf
also imparts dawa training to D to aply
convey The Message of Islam Dr Zakir Nik
president of irf reaching out across
countries worldwide from America to
Europe to Africa to Asia to Australia
strives to clarify Islamic viewpoints he
dispels the many media mits and
anti-islamic prejudices propagated the
world over by anti-islamic forces irf
today is creating a change in the hearts
and minds of millions of Muslims and
non-muslims worldwide towards a proper
understanding and respect for Islam have
a question or doubt about Islam and its
teachings now you know one of the best
Resource Centers to get convincing
answers from is Islamic Research
Foundation Mumbai India for more
information log on to our website
www.ir f.net glory be to
Allah all praise to
Allah there is no God but
Allah
Allah is great all power and might
belong to
Allah the most high the great we made
peace a symbol of vs in the name of
Peace We Gather here now oh Lord please
make these days of vs on this Earth fill
[Music]
with
We Begin today's program with the kirat
the recitation from the Holy Quran by
Brother Ashraf
[Music]
muhammadi
r
[Music]
for
the translation from Surah Alon chapter
23: 1 to
11 I seek Refuge with Allah from Satan
the accursed in the name of Allah most
gracious most
merciful the Believers must eventually
win through those who humble themselves
in their prayers who avoid vain talk who
are active in Deeds of Charity who
abstain from sex except with those
joined to them in the marriage bond or
the captives whom their right hands
possess for in their case they are free
from blame but those whose desires
exceed those limits are
transgressors those who Faithfully
observe their trust and Covenant and who
strictly God their prayers this will be
the hirs who will inherit Paradise they
will dwell therein
forever verily Allah has spoken the
truth respected brothers and
sisters assalamu alayum may peace be on
you on behalf of the Islamic Research
Foundation I Dr Muhammad n welcome all
of you to today's
program the Islamic Research Foundation
strives for Islamic dawa the proper
presentation clarification and
understanding of The Message of Islam as
well as removing misconceptions about
Islam amongst less aware Muslims as well
as
non-muslims reason logic and modern
scientific understanding are the basis
of all its
presentations the regular programs of
the Islamic Research Foundation include
organizing public lectures followed by
open question and answer sessions
symposia open Forum interactions and
such programs may Allah subhana wa
ta'ala accept our striving in his way
and grant us more opportunities and will
to serve his Dean dedicatedly a mean Dr
Zakir NY is the president of the Islamic
Research
Foundation Dr Zakir has left his medical
profession to devote himself
wholeheartedly in spreading the truth of
Islam as well as removing misconceptions
about Islam amongst non-muslims as well
as less aware Muslims especially through
his public talks and TV programs the
world over he's appreciated more so for
his convincing answers to challenging
questions posed by audiences and critics
at his public
talks Salah is the most important pillar
of Islam after Iman or
faith Salah is the Arabic term for the
Muslim prayer which is commonly known as
namas in Udu today Dr Zakir will present
the Islamic perspective and concept of
Salah and its objectives in it talk on
Salah the programming towards
righteousness brothers and sisters Dr
Zakir
NY
alhamdulillah
my respected elders and my dear brothers
and sisters I welcome all of you with
the Islamic
greetings
may peace blessings and mercy of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala be on all of
you the topic of this morning's talk is
Salah the programming towards
righteousness most of the people they
translate Salah into English as the
prayer the prayer is not the exact
translation of the Arabic word
Salah because to pray means to beseech
to ask
earnestly like how you pray or beseech
in a court of
law to pray means to supplicate to ask
for
help the Dua is the supplication the
prayer Salah is not merely to pray it
means much more than that because in
Salah besides asking for help from Allah
subhana wa ta'ala we Muslims we also
praise him we also receive guidance from
him and the Salah simultaneously is a
sort of
programming it is a conditioning or in
Lay man's terminology it is
brainwashing
but if someone is going to offer
Salah and if a person asks him that
where are you going and if he says he's
going for brainwashing or if he's going
for programming it will sound odd
therefore I personally do not mind if
people use the word prayer for the
Arabic word Salah but they should
remember that Salah is much more than
merely to
pray the
moment you heard the word
programming you start thinking of a
computer if you allow me to call the
human being a machine I would say it's
the most complicated machine on the face
of the Earth it is much more complicated
than the most advanced computer in the
world and we human beings we are
the the best of creations of Allah
subhana wa tala and the Holy Quran says
in chapter number 95 verse number
four that verily we have created the
human beings in the best of
moldes the
psychologists they tell us that our mind
is not directly under our control
the body is directly under our control
if I want to lift my hand I can lift it
if I want to bring it down I can bring
it down if I want to take a step forward
I can take it the body is directly under
our control but the mind is not directly
under our control therefore most of us
we might have experienced that while we
offer Salah our mind keeps on wandering
and
suppose if a student after appearing for
his
examination if he offers
Salah he starts reviewing his
examination paper in the
Salah he starts thinking that the answer
I gave to question two instead of this I
should have written
that if a businessman offer Salah he
starts thinking that how much profit
have I made today how how much good did
I
sell if a housewife if she offer Salah
she may start thinking that what should
I cook for my husband should I cook
biryani or should I cook
Pula it's very common that during Salah
our mind keeps on
wandering why does the mind wander the
reason is because our mind is empty and
a mind cannot remain
empty therefore it
wanders most of the
Muslims they know the basic things that
we recite in our
Salah the Surah fa and the few verses of
the Holy Quran or the short suras of the
Holy Quran which we recite in the
Salah we
Muslims we recite it so mechanically
that even if you wake up a Muslim from
the middle of his sleep and ask him to
recite Sur faat he can do it 100
miles it's
mechanical and because it is mechanical
only a minute portion of a mind is
utilized in reciting the mechanical
portion which we know by heart that is
Surah FAA and the other vers of the Holy
Quran
most of us Muslims since we are
non-arabs we don't understand Arabic as
a language and because we don't
understand what we are reciting in a
Salah there are high possibilities of
our mind wandering therefore to prevent
our mind from
wandering we should recite the Arabic
portion and simultaneously recall the
meaning of the things you are reciting
in the the
Salah if you know
English recall the English
translation if you know Udu recall the
Udu
translation if you know Hindi recall it
in Hindi if you know marati recall it in
marati if you know Gujarati recall it in
Gujarati recall the meaning of the
things you're reciting in the language
you understand
best for
example when we recite s fa this
in the name of Allah most gracious most
merciful
alhamdulillah praise be to Allah the
lord of the
world most merciful most
gracious the master of the day of
judgment the alone we worship the alone
we ask for
help show us the straight
path the path of those who have earned
th favor and of those whose path is not
Roth nor who go
astray when we
recite the Surah FAA all the other
verses in Arabic simultaneously recall
the meaning and your mind will not
wander
because again your mind is occupied in
recalling the meaning of the Arabic
portion that you're reciting in your
Salah but after a few weeks a few months
even this becomes mechanical your mind
is very powerful you recite the Arabic
portion and recall the meaning because
the mind is very powerful and again
there are chances your mind will divert
but there left chances because a little
portion of your mind is occupied in
reciting the Arabic portion and another
recalling the meaning there are less
chances it will divert but yet it may
wander to prevent your mind from
wandering besides reciting the Arabic
portion and recalling the meaning you
should even
concentrate on what you are reciting and
recording
a human being cannot concentrate 100% on
two different things he can concentrate
50% on two different things or 80% 20%
but 100% on two different things he
can't concentrate so the more you
concentrate the less your mind will
wander so to prevent your mind from
wandering you should recite the Arabic
portion recall its meaning and
concentrate on the meaning then
inshallah your mind will will not
wonderer I started my
talk by quoting a verse from the Holy
Quran from chapter number 29 verse
number 45 he
says which means recite of what we have
sent by inspiration of the book to
the and establish regular prayer
for verily prayers restrain you from
shameful and unjust
deed the Holy Quran says that Salah
restrains you from shameful and unjust
deed as I mentioned earlier Salah is a
sort of
programming it's a programming towards
righteousness and we Muslims we are
programmed five times a day in our
Salah and we ask for guidance from Allah
subhana
tala show us the straight path and Allah
subhana wa ta'ala gives the answers he
programs us towards
righteousness for example the
Imam after Surah
FAA he may
recite chapter number five verse number
19 which
says oh you who
believe most certainly intoxicant and
gambling dedication of stones divination
of
arrows these are Satan's
handwork abstain from this handiwork
that you may
Prosper here we are being programmed in
the
Salah that you should abstain from
intoxicant from gambling from idol
worship from fortune
telling because these are Satan's
hand the
IM he made aite after Surah faat Sur ma
chapter number five verse number three
which
says foring for you for food are dead
meat blood the Flesh of swine and any
food on which any name besides Allah has
been
invoked here we are being programmed in
the Salah that the foods that you should
never have the Forin foods are dead meat
blood the Flesh of swine and any food on
which any name besides Allah has been
invoked on it we are being programmed
towards
righteousness the Imam after Surah faat
he may recite Surah Al is chapter 17
verse number 23- 24 which says that
Allah subhana wa ta'ala has ordained for
you that you worship none but him and
that you be kind to your parents and if
any one of them or both of them Reach
old age do not say a word of contempt
don't even say off to
them but address them with humility and
lower your wing of kindness to them and
and pray to the Lord that have mercy on
them as they cherished me in childhood
we are being programmed that we have to
be good to your parents and if any one
of them or both of them Reach old age
yet you should not even say off to
them we are being programmed in our
Salah the computer normally requires
programming only once but since the
human mind has a free will of its own
which the computer doesn't have the
human beings have to be programmed
regularly because the amount of wrong
things we see around us in the
society like East teasing bribing
cheating robbing alcoholism drug
addiction molestation there are high
chances that our mind can get
deprogrammed therefore we have to be
kept on being regularly programmed to
keep us on
theim on the straight
path some people may
ask that why don't you offer Salah only
once why offer five times a day for a
healthy body a human being requires
minimum three meals a day if he has one
meal a
day he will not have a very healthy body
similarly for a spiritual Soul a human
being requires minimum five times of
programming five times of
Salah one is not sufficient that's the
reason we Muslims we offer Salah five
times a
day the
Jews they offer prayers three times a
day which is also mentioned in the Old
Testament in the book of Daniels chapter
number 6 verse number
10 we Muslims we offer minimum five
times Salah every
day and it's a commandment of Allah
subhana waala which has been given to
all the Muslims and it's mentioned in
the Holy Quran in surah h chapter number
11 verse number
114 in Surah isra chapter 17 verse
number 78 in Surah Taha chapter number
20 verse number 130 and Surah Room
chapter number 30 verse number 17 and 18
these few wordss of the Holy Quran they
instruct the Muslims to offer Salah five
times a
day the five daily Salas which we
Muslims should offer are the F
Salah which
begins from anytime between the break of
dawn till just Before
Sunrise the second is the Zar
Salah after the Sun reaches its highest
point from the decline of the sun till
the midpoint between noon and
sunset third is the
Salah after the Zar Salah ends until
just before Sunset the fourth is the m
Salah
immediately after sunsets till the end
of Twilight and is Salah immediately
after Twilight it can be offered before
midnight a Muslim should offer Salah
minimum five times a
day and when we offer Salah and before
we enter the mosque we Muslims we remove
our
footway and this was the same
commandment which was given by Allah
subhana wa tala to M Alam Moses peace be
upon him which is mentioned in the Holy
Quran in Surah T chapter number 20 verse
number 11 and
12 when he approached the fire he heard
a voice oh Moses verily I am thy Lord
put off thy shoes for thou art in the
sacred Valley of
Tua this was a commandment
given by Allah subhana wa ta'ala to to
mus
Alam a similar message is
mentioned in the Bible in the Old
Testament in the book of
Exodus chapter number three verse number
five it says he Lord Almighty says to
Moses draw not n hither take off thy
shoes from thy
feet for thou art on sacred grounds
a similar message is repeated in the
book of Acts chapter number 7 verse
number 33 the Lord tells to Moses put
off thy shoes from thy feet for thou art
on sacred
grounds and we Muslims we are even given
the option to wear the shoes when we
enter the MOs or when we offer Salah by
our beloved Prophet Muhammad sallallahu
Ali
wasallam our beloved Prophet said but
when you wear the shoes the soul should
be clean and it's
mentioned in Abu daud volume number
one in the book of
Salah Salah chapter number 240 Hadith
number 652 the prophet said be different
than the
Jews for they always during prayer
remove their shoes or sandals
it's also mentioned in Abu da Vol number
one in theab Salah chapter number 240
Hadith number
653 that Amin on the authority of his
father said that his grandfather said I
saw the prophet pray both barefooted and
with
sandals the reason we Muslims we take
off our shoes before we enter the mosque
offer Salah or clean the souls of of our
shoes is because we are hygienic people
we want to keep our place of worship
clean before we offer
Salah there is a call for prayers
and in different religions you have
different ways of calling people to come
to
prayer for
example the Jews they use the trumpet as
it's mentioned in the Bible in the Book
of Numbers Chapter number 10: 1 to3 Lord
spake to Moses and told him to make Two
Trumpets of silver and to use it to call
the assembly the Christians they use the
church belt some tribes they use the
drum in Islam we use the human
voice and the call for prayer is is
called as
Adan and the person who gives the Adan
is
called
a the human voice is much more melodious
and soothing as compared to the trumpet
Bell or
drum and
there is a much better
impact on the human being
there are many
non-muslims who have reverted to Islam
only by hearing the Adan they were so
impressed with the melod Adan which had
a tremendous effect on their heart mind
and soul that they accepted
Islam but unfortunately all the Adan
that we have in Bombay they aren't as
melodious as they should be and they
cause more inconvenience to the human
being than
Tranquility therefore I request all the
M that they should hear the Adan of the
Shar m in Madina and M Haram in Makkah
as an example of what Adan should be
like besides the Adan being melodious
and soothing it also carries a
message but unfortunately most of the
non-muslims
they do not know what the message of the
Adan
is last
December I had been to Kerala to attend
a conference organized by the Muslims in
which they also invited a non-muslim
minister who was giving a talk on the
stage and he was speaking a few good
words about the Muslims and about
Islam and he said that we Indians we are
very proud of the
Muslims we are proud of the Mogul rulers
the amount of monumental buildings they
made the beautiful structures they made
no wonder you Muslims you praise Emperor
abbar five times a
day it may sound like a joke but it's
very common that many non-muslims think
especially of India that we praise
emperor abbar in the Adan and in our
Salah there are some non-muslims who are
impressed by the western
movies which very often show the actor
dressed up in an Arab gab who's a
villain who's a
terrorist and before he draws out his
sword he says Allah
abbar so non-muslims think that Allah
abbar is a walk cry which the Muslims
give before killing the non-muslims
it the duty of every Muslim to clarify
these
misconceptions from the minds of the
non-muslims and we should give the
message of Adan tell them the
translation of the
Adan
that when we give the Adan and when we
recite Allah abbar Allah abbar Allah
abbar
abbar it doesn't mean that we're
praising Emperor abbar or it's a walk
cry but it means Allah subhana wa ta'ala
is the
greatest almighty God is the greatest
Allah is the greatest Allah is the
greatest I bear
witness that there is no one worthy of
worship but Allah subhana tala I bear
witness that there's no diety but Allah
I bear witness that Muhammad peace be
upon Him is the messenger of Allah
subhana wa tala I bear witness that
Muhammad peace be upon Him is the
messenger of Allah subhana wa
tala come for Salah come for Salah come
to prayer come to
prayer come to success come to
success Allah abar Allah abbar
Allah is the greatest Allah is the
greatest there is no God but
Allah we
have to explain the meaning of the Adan
to the
non-muslims it is the duty of the
Muslims that we deliver the message of
Islam and explain about it to the
non-muslims and before we offer
Salah we always have to do
ablution that is we have to wash
ourselves that is we have to do
woo this is mentioned in the Holy Quran
in Sur chapter number
five verse number six
that oh you who believe when you prepare
yourself for
Salah wash your faith and your hands and
arms up to the
Elbow rub your head with
water and wash your feet up to the
ankle it's compulsory that every Muslim
should do ablution should do wo before
we offer our
Salah and a similar message is given in
the Holy Bible in the book of
Exodus chapter number 140
verse number 31 and 32 that Moses and
Aaron and their sons washed their hands
and feet thereat and they entered the
Temple of the congregation and when they
approached the altar they washed as was
commanded by the Lord to
Moses a similar message is given in
Acts chapter number 21 verse number 26
and Paul took the men away and the next
day along with them he purified himself
and entered the
temple we Muslims we do ablution we wash
ourself we do the woodoo before we offer
the
Salah to keep ourselves clean we are
hygienic people and
besides keeping ourselves clean the
wodoo is also a sort of psychological
preparation a mental
preparation that we do before we
communicate with Allah subhana wa ta'ala
and our beloved Prophet
said it's mentioned s bukari volum
number one in the book of Salah chapter
number 56 Hadith number
429 that the Earth is made as a place
for me and my followers to do sujud as a
Masjid Masjid means
a place to do suud our Prophet said that
the whole world the complete Earth is a
Masjid for the
Believers but natural the place where
you offer your Salah where you do suud
it should be clean it's also mentioned
in
sari Vol number one in the book of Adan
chapter 75 Hadith number 692 anas may
Allah be pleased with him he said that
the companions when they stood for Salah
his shoulder touched with the shoulder
of His companion and his foot touched
with the foot of His companion a similar
message repeated in the book of Salah in
Abu daud in chapter number
245 Hadith number
666 the Beloved
Prophet before starting the Salah he
said straighten your roles stand
shoulder toh shoulder Clos in the gaps
and do not leave any opening for the
Devil the prophet was not referring to
the devil which you see in the Onida TV
ad on the comic strip with two horns and
a
tail the prophet was referring to the
devil of
rism of cast of color of wealth
irrespective whether they black or white
whether rich or poor whether king or
poer to whichever family you may belong
when you stand for Salah stand shoulder
to
shoulder the basic method the outline of
offering Salah is given in a nutshell in
the Holy
Quran the Holy Quran says in Sur Al Bak
chapter number
two verse number
144 that turn your face to the sacred
MOS wherever you are turn your face in
that direction
it's compulsory that when we offer Salah
we should face the that's towards the
sacred mosque towards
Caba and in India we Muslims we have to
face
towards the
west and when I travel in
India if I don't know the kiah the
direction and if I have to ask a
non-muslim I do not ask him where is the
West what I do is I ask him where is the
East and then I face in the opposite
direction otherwise he may think that we
are worshiping the Western
World the Holy Quran says in Surah Al
bakar chapter 2 verse number
238 that when you stand for remembering
Allah stand in a devout frame of
mind the Holy Quran says stand in a
devout frame of mind when you offer
Salah and reciting Surah faat is
compulsory in the Salah and it's also
mentioned in Surah alh chter 15 verse
number 87 that we have sent to you the
offre repeated seven verses and the
grand Quran the off repeated seven
verses refers to Surah FAA and it's also
called as the minor Quran and the other
portion of the Quran is called as the
grand Quran it's compulsory that we
should recite Sur FAA in every
Salah
the word Ruku that is bowing is
mentioned in the Holy Quran no less than
times and the word sujud which is the
best part of the Salah is mentioned in
the Holy Quran no less than 92 times and
it's mentioned in 32 different suras of
the Holy Quran and there is a separate
chapter chapter number 32 called as ass
the
prostration
and the Holy Quran says inah Al Imran 3
verse number
43 oh Mary worship thy love
devotedly prostrate thyself and bow down
with those who bow down the Holy Quran
says in Surah ha 22 verse
77 all you who believe prostate and bow
down and humble yourself and do good
Good Deeds that you may
Prosper every prophet of Allah subhana
wa ta'ala when he offered his
prayer to Allah subhana wa taala he did
sujud he did prostration all the
prophets and a similar message is also
given in the Bible if you read in the
Old Testament in the Book of Genesis
chapter number 17 verse number three
says Abraham fell on his face Book of
Numbers Chapter number 20 verse number 6
Moses and Aaron fell on their face book
of Joshua chapter number 5 verse number
14 Joshua fell on his face to the Earth
anded worship it's mentioned in the Holy
Bible in the gospel of Matthew chapter
number 26 verse number 39 that when
Jesus peace be upon Him goes to the
Garden of Gethsemane he takes a few
steps forward falls on his face and does
prayer all the prophets of almighty God
dided the sujud for offering
Salah and even an acrobat cannot do
better than what we Muslims do when the
Bible says fall on your faith and pray
to God the way we Muslims
do the reason we do fud is as I
mentioned earlier the mind is not
directly under our control the body is
directly under our control and in order
to Humble the mind you also have to
Humble the body and there is no better
way of humbling the body than to put the
highest part of the body the forehead
which also has the frontal lobe of the
brain which is the most important organ
to the lowest part on the ground and
then say glory be to Allah the most high
glory be to Allah the most
high regarding the minute
details of how to offer Salah where to
keep the hand how to stand how to sit
Etc how many to offer the Holy Quran
says obey Allah and obey the messenger
you have to look at the prophet the
Quran
says in several places inah Al Imran CH
number 3 vers number 32 in Surah Al
Imran CH number 3 verse number 132 inah
4 verse 59 in Surah ma 5: 92 in Surah
anfal chter number 8 verse number one in
Surah an CH number 8 verse number 20
inah anal chter number 8 verse number 46
in Sur chter number 24 verse 54 in Sur
CH 24 ver 56 in Surah Muhammad 47 verse
number 33 in Surah muad 58 verse number
13 in several places inah chapter number
64 verse number 12 the Holy Quran
says obey Allah and obey the messenger
for the minute details look at the
prophet and it's mentioned in s bukari
volume number one in the book of Adan
chapter number 18 Hadith number 604 as
well as in s bukari volume number n
Hadith number 352 the prophet said pray
as you have seen me
praying pray as you have seen me praying
for minute details you have to refer to
the authentic
had the
Salah is the most important pillar of
Islam after Imam after
faith and the Holy Quran says
inah 51 verse
56 that I have created the Jin and the
men not but to worship
me and the Arabic word I comes from the
root word AB which means a slave a
servant it's the duty of every servant
to be obedient to his master and every
human being is a servant of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala of almighty God and
it's the duty of every human being to be
obedient to Allah subhana wa ta'ala
the moment you follow the Commandments
of Allah subhana wa ta'ala you are doing
I you are doing
worship if you abstain from the things
which Allah subhana wa ta'ala has
prohibited you from from doing you are
doing
I many people have the misconception
that Salah is the only form of
I in fact Salah is the most important
form of I but it's not the only form of
I following the Commandments of Allah
subhana wa taala is I and Salah is the
most important form of
I
Salah can also mean rendering obedience
you can only be obedient if you know
what you're reciting in your Salah if
you know what Allah subhana wa ta'ala
has commanded you to do therefore it's
compulsory that every Muslim should know
what he's reciting in his Salah he
should also read the Holy
Quran if he doesn't understand Arabic he
should also read its translation its
meaning so that he can Implement on the
Commandments of Allah subhana wa ta'ala
there are various dangers
if a person doesn't offer
Salah there are chances your faith can
become weak or it can even get
lost because the human being thinks that
the wellbe and honor that he has is due
to the worldly material things and he
goes away from Allah subhana wa tala
there is lack of discipline when he goes
away from Allah subhana wa ta'ala
to acquire the worldly desires the
material things there are chances that
he may do Foul Play and go away from
theim from the straight
path there is lack of inner
peace irrespective how much wealth a
person has the wealth cannot gain him
peace and the
reason that the
people don't offer Salah is due to lack
of
knowledge the Holy Quran says in Surah
Al Imran chapter 3 verse number
185 Every Soul shall have a taste of
death and you shall have your total
recompense on the day of
judgment and only he who is saved from
the Hellfire and is admitted to the
gardens shall have achieve the
objectives of the life for verily the
life in this world is a mere deception
of goods and
chattles there are various benefits of
offering
Salah Salah is a way of
life it
caters to the spiritual aspect of your
soul and the physical needs of your
body the Salah
it increases your faith it strengthens
your faith the Holy Quran says in Surah
anal chapter number8 verse number two
that the True Believers are those who
when Allah is mentioned feel a trauma in
the heart and when his signs are
rehearsed it strengthens their faith and
they put their complete trust in Allah
subhana wa
tala the Holy Quran says in Surah fatia
1: 5 to
seven the alone we worship there alone
we ask for
help show us the straight path the path
of those who have earned High
favor and of those whose path is not
wough nor who go astray it increases the
discipline of your life a true Muslim he
starts his day by offering the Salah and
in the Salah the in the he also
adds that Salah is better than sleep
offering prayer is better than
sleeping and a true Muslim at intervals
he offer Salah and he ends his day with
the ISA Salah before he goes to
sleep the Salah it also improves the
social conditions
the congregational Salah it increases
the Brotherhood the fraternity the unity
and is an example of
equality the solidarity increases when
the people of the community they meet
each other and the love and affection
between them
increases the Holy Quran says in Surah
huat chapter 49 verse number
oh humankind we have created you from a
single pair of male and female and have
divided you into Nations and tribes so
that you shall recognize each other not
that you shall despise each other and
the most
honored in the sight of Allah subhana wa
ta'ala is the person who has tawa who
has
righteousness and Allah is all knowing
full of
wisdom the criteria for judgment in the
sight of Allah subhana wa ta'ala it's
not cast it's not color it's not Creed
it's not wealth it's not sex but it is
tawa it's righteousness it's God
Consciousness it's
piety the Holy Quran says in Surah humza
104 verse number
one wo to every kind of Scandal manga
and back biter the Salah prevents us
from Scandal monging and
backbiting the Holy Quran says in Surah
huat chter 49 verse number 11 and
12 oh you who believe let not men
amongst you laugh at others you may
never know that the latter may be better
than the
former let not women laugh at others you
may never know that the latter may be
better than the former